[Music]
[Music]
are you doing called driving Marcus
[Music]
throwdown what four minutes
speed up oh sit you want me to speed up
and slow down at the same time moving
southbound on Collins copy that
your support has a visual
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm about to throw up
oh you've bet to hell not that is
hand-stitched leather you better drink
it damn it
look you are a navigator okay that's why
you're sitting in that seat and where
are your glasses you need to put your
glasses on I don't need glasses
Marcus you can't see [ __ ]
[Music]
sorry rich white people but not this
black we cops too
to pull ourselves over made up
[Music]
hey even the Batmobile don't hold a road
like this [ __ ]
get me the [ __ ] out of this car oh [ __ ]
oh come on man you could get that buffed
out no you can get that buffed out hole
make a hole baby I'm sorry
[Music]
daddy Joker you a pop-up
Oh baby look at no doubt it's in the
eyes and the ears and the name Marcus
smiles brunette that's my name his name
too
we decided to name him after you I was
Reggie's idea thought it would be a very
respectful justice I hope you're proof
that's cool but you know you still need
to make an honest woman out of my baby
girl there Uncle Mike wait hold the baby
oh no I don't want to catch that okay
just that [ __ ] oh my stop baby stop it
right now seriously okay you know what
I'll be outside when you get your [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Jimmy
[Music]
[Music]
mama
we go
no ss3 Stevo sue Martin
[Music]
el espíritu para estar libre de la rocca
screens arava a step while último regalo
to pop and accumulator es su nombre i
finished as listo para lo que sí tiene
cancer never addressed alone or el
respeto a nuestra familia to padre en
contra la forma desk under millones de
dólares antes de sera sera no aqui esta
la scala nadas para que los bus keys
vamos al Cooper Alok is mister
este dinero knows betrayer venganza in
an mente
la gente que destrosa nuestra familia
vas a ver lo que se siente sir
Meza heroes
l am where a loyal team
we're here to celebrate let's raise the
glass what about all and I sincerely
hope that someday your namesake follows
in the footsteps of his old dance
grandpa to protect and serve our
offensive to Marcus
may the name Marcus Burnett strike fear
into the hearts and minds of [ __ ]
for years to come
thank you thank thank you all
Mike and I we're going on 25 years of
working these streets and I like to
think we made a difference you all are
the best and I thank you it's been a
real hard anybody that casts deep huh
the bins are empty you spilled very
treasure notion I heard the stories
below coin you should cover the cost of
the materials we discussed and then some
this is what you get
did you say
we had a deal renegotiating
[Music]